how many of you are not listening to the
fake news Democrats say she's dangerous
actually stand up turn around and raise
your hand if you're not listening to the
thing an election denying ex-tv host
running for Arizona governor is that
great Curry lake is endorsed by Donald
Trump and is spending the final hours of
this campaign aping his style call it
what it is an invasion on our border and
take back border security and secure our
border we're all Patriots and we are
going to fight like hell to save this
country they started going after our
babies that was the biggest mistake they
ever made the most dangerous place in
all of nature is between a mama bear and
her baby cub and the left is right there
and we're going to rip them to shreds
flanked by Trump Ally Steve Bannon this
is not a campaign this is a movement
she's proved a sensation at these
elections
of course carriele cannot help
all the house
he wants is here in Arizona not in
Washington but there is a buzz around
her Campaign which perhaps points to
something far more significant a new
generation of right-wing celebrity
politicians who may continue the
controversial Legacy of Donald Trump
they certainly seem newer and fresher
than President Biden who is facing
inflation highs and approval lows it
isn't a referendum it's a choice
it's a choice between two fundamentally
different visions of America Donald
Trump knows a red Republican wave could
be the perfect Prelude to another
presidential Bid And if you want to stop
the destruction of our country and save
the American dream you don't hear too
much about the American dream over the
last two years then this Tuesday you
must go out and vote Republican back in
Arizona
as across the country key issues include
immigration and the economy yeah feed
your family and by gasoline to go to
work and she has a plan to fix all that
immigration is a big issue for people
here totally yeah yes we live here
they're coming over the Border Big Time
have you not watched the news lately and
some are already casting doubts about
the Integrity of this vote are you
worried this election may not be fair
would you accept the result I worry
because my opponent is running the
elections her name's Katie Hobbs she's
incompetent it's not just me saying that
the Arizona Supreme Court called her
incompetent and we've already seen how
she's botched many elections are you
accusing her of fraud though Miss Lake
I'm in Q I'm accusing her of being
absolutely incompetent in a worthless
Secretary of State
if Republicans win here those who
publicly questioned the last
presidential election will be
responsible for overseeing the next one
in a state which could swing who is in
the White House Joe Pike Sky News
Phoenix Arizona